European elections part 3,
what you vote for and how to vote at 06/2024 you vote and vote
to elect the members of the European Parliament
in Italy we read 76 and Who they are.
The electoral law broadly works like this,
it is proportional,
so each party reads a number of parliamentarians in proportion to the
votes it takes 20% of the votes equals 20% of the seats Parties
that do not exceed 4% of the votes,
however,
are excluded from the count.
It's called a barrier threshold.
There are 5 constituencies,
, Northwest,
South Center and islands Each of these has its own list of candidates for each
party and which parliamentarians within a list are chosen depends on us
because you choose with preferences,
it means you vote Both a party or a list and you choose up to 3 candidates from
that list You can vote up to 3 provided they are not all of the same sex Between
the parliamentarians elected by a party VA in bruxelle Who has taken more preferences
and here's what you vote for 06/2024 If you have other doubts or curiosities about
the European elections write it in the comments hello.